keep it simple i always think about  mcdonald's okay what would mcdonald's do  mark twain said the difference between  the right word and wrong word is the  difference between lightning and the  lightning bug but now there's a new mark  in town and his name is mark norman and  he's one of the best wordsmiths in the  game because of this simple trick keep  it simple i always think about  mcdonald's okay what would mcdonald's do  you know if this has got to be it's got  to appeal to everybody and it's got to  be easy to understand it's like a  website you ever go on a website you're  like what you read legal jargon you're  like what the [ __ ] is this  i think you gotta just make it so it's  buttons and letters and colors you know  just easy peasy to figure out